you can watch my next guests on high
heat on MLB Network at 4 p.m. Eastern
then listen to him on Sirius XM's mad
dog Unleashed at 5:00 Eastern from
Nationals Park today and tomorrow he is
none other than Chris Mad Dog rousu
[Music]
Chris Brockman from Maine and from other
parts what's the first all-star game you
ever went to
wen-chi well I remember the game here in
69 McCovey hit the two homeruns that's
the last all-star game and yeah this
area boy went - I'd have to think about
that probably I went to a lot of them
with Mike and the old days yes
the 92 game which was a fun game was a
93 is that it was 92 in Camden Yards
that's when Juan Gonzalez won a homerun
Derby and Griffey was trying to hit the
warehouse out in right field yeah and
the homerun Derby in those days was in
the afternoon it wasn't at night right
like it was today so you was hot weather
balls flying out of there
there's 93 that because the Giants and
Braves had that great pennant race
I remember that one really well I
remember the 94 all-star game in
Pittsburgh and we had Mickey Mantle it
was a year before he died in the booth
which is interesting what do you mean
you had him in the booth Three Rivers
and they had a celebrity thing that are
like a celebrity softball game right we
were at that and that's the game that
Gwyn scored the winning run on a Fred
McGriff base hit what was it like
talking to make them out it was good we
had Mickey man on a couple of times Mike
loved them I remember we had him on at
Mickey Mantle's
restaurant one when he wrote a book and
you know did a lot we have we know that
was right and never never had DiMaggio
but we had we did have Mickey never had
Mays but we did have Mickey on we had
him on then that was after Mickey said
you know I had problem with alcohol yeah
that was after you did the Costas thing
right you know we did the big Costas
interview before he had deliver cancer
before was before that was between the
96 all-star game I went to in Philly
that's at the Bicentennial in Philly
when the when he when Piazza hit the
home run to win a game and bonds won the
home run hitting contest so I've been a
Ben
a lot of them my the Yankee Stadium one
was great no wait one where Hamilton
went yard Yankee Stadium so that was
good too so the all-star games always
had its niche it really has so I know
you said in the television only segment
that you had you conducted a town hall
with the commissioner Rob Manfred is on
this show tomorrow right and that you
hid all the topics that you think needed
to be hid what were those topics that
you had with you know taste the play and
know and I like to you know perk up the
offense with all the strikeouts what do
you say well I mean they've come up with
you know the ships we did a little bit I
gotta get rid of him gotta get rid of me
never a lot of this has to be negotiated
with the Union and the Union right now
and baseball they're a little bit apart
partly because of the coldness in the
offseason with free agents so the
relationship between the Players
Association and a Commissioner's Office
on the Players Association angle isn't
cooperative so that is a and you can't
put in these changes look how long it
took him to get the mound visits and the
intentional walk no pitch clock hmm so
they've had some issues both sides
reaching agreement on some game changes
thaws you got a problem well I would
think some left-handed hitters would not
mind to get rid of this part part of the
Union would like to get rid of this you
can make that argument too now you can
you can also make this point where they
don't tell Belichick how to deploy
here's 11 defenders if they want to put
a defensive lineman in coverage they
wanna blitz a corner whatever they want
to do you know they might have some
rules with pump and run and all that
five yards but they don't tell them
where to deploy his personnel you want a
triple team LeBron you can do that you
can play zone so maybe the deployment of
your defenders should be sacristy be
really religious a crescent that you
should not be able to tell the the
defense the the manager where it can
place his players but defensively the
difference and here's how
would come back to this Kris Mad Dog
Rousseau is that yes
you can't tell Belichick what to do on
defense and you can't defend or tell the
defenders of LeBron how to defend LeBron
right but LeBron has the ball in
football the offense as the ball in
baseball only sport where defense has
the ball possession of the ball is
already in the hand that's fair defend
thought of it that way and so you have
to if you see what is happening come up
with something certainly since you're
totally confused sometimes if you're a
kid out there you know how the hell is
the third baseman suddenly in short
right field like like they're playing a
softball game you know to me it's up to
the offense to adapt but that's a good
point yeah that's a very good point the
other thing that I think I don't know
how baseball solves his problem you know
remember the star pitcher in baseball is
out of the game in his sixth inning
velia
Nadal and Federer play a fifth set
LeBron's playing in the fourth quarter
Brady's playing in the fourth air
playing in the fourth quarter Verlander
well he different but most of the great
pitchers don't complete the game so you
never see the great pitcher reach deep
into the tank to see what's left to let
him gut his way through a big game in
september/october because he's out of
the game in a sixth inning what do you
think Tampa's a few times where they
start the closer what's so so you think
we're gonna get to an age where
relievers pitch the first second third
fourth innings and the starters come in
or the big-name players and they're the
closer fourth and they pitched the rest
of the game remember you see the tampers
do it because Tampa cannot afford the
huge pitcher well as result that's
that's a small market but if Earl Anders
throwing 100 pitches and he's in the
eighth inning he's got to come out right
he starts if he enters the game in the
fourth inning he can pitch into there an
eleventh or twelfth to fit guys extras
like you're also messing with a guy
who's pitched for 15 years that's a
weird thing form he all bets are off in
baseball yeah I mean I listen you can
make that work but you have to convince
the starter that you're not gonna start
the game you gonna pitch the third and
fourth it
that is a little different adjusted up
he would slow get the win but to your
point Chris that's what was so amazing
about Verlander's postseason spots and
bass mostly bass was lost a little bit
of that because of the advent of the
Greeley picture right interestingly
enough to Chris mad dog Rousseau here on
the Rich Eisen show from the DC all-star
game that I had somebody who is high up
in Major League Baseball tell me and I
mentioned just threw it out there that
it was the st. what again what it was
was letting the ninth inning of a team
that's losing put anybody up the first
three batters in the ninth inning anew
and and the same exact reasoning as you
just gave me about the starting pitcher
was told to me by this individual play
let the best players play in the ninth
inning that Brady doesn't sit when the
game's on the line and the Patriots have
the ball Danny Crosby doesn't come off
the ice good point
Reynaldo doesn't come off the pitch
excellent point that's what they all
said and and the human crime you got a
lot of people you know you know the way
that they forward I showed you the past
shows you baseball fans are passionate
losing team you are shutting the great
you're making it unfair for the team
that's ahead right your team that's had
the great pitching performance but
you're saying right now it doesn't even
matter if any of this makes complete
sense that the Players Association
interesting opinion on this I mean that
stats you know that says you can ask the
Commissioner when you have him on
tomorrow I do think there is a little
remember we read the quotes a lot of the
players and they were wrong because all
the deals were good deals but I know the
players feel that there was a freeze out
in last year's offseason that gets to
Clark and he's not willing to be
cooperative right now and you got to
negotiate all these with the Union so
that's something to keep an eye on other
than that in the listen you're gonna
have a tremendous postseason in baseball
you know you're gonna have used
the Red Sox the Yankees probably the
Dodgers the Cubs you are gonna have some
big you're gonna have some weight I mean
how about a Yankee how about a Yankee
Astral games a seven-game series well I
mean they're selling red sock astronaut
says one of those seems gonna have to
get past the Red Sox first remember the
wild card winner let's say the Red Sox
have the best record the Yankees will
play Seattle or Oakland and if they win
they get the Red Sox in the first round
because the Red Sox play the fourth seed
and a wild-card teams the fourth see
they don't go by record they do it by
seeds so the Red Sox and Yankees to play
a five-game series and it wouldn't would
get used to well we were discussing that
spring will be all jacked up cuz he had
to play the one game playoff the Yankees
without the pitch Severino we're not one
game just say low pitch in that game if
he doesn't win right how about that I
mean the the the the Oakland Athletics
are 13 over right what a job they've
done they are two wins better than the
NL East leading Philadelphia they feed
back a covey of Seattle eight back
behind the defending World Series champs
I do want to take a 60-second break come
back ask you that poll question that we
had which current 60 win team is the
best chance to win the World Series and
then uh you know what I want to talk I
will give you the usual Christopher mad
dog Russo wanting it wanting to ask me
an uncomfortable question about the
Nationals will do okay we're back in 60
seconds with Chris Beto back F that is
all right back here in Washington DC
another segment with Chris mad dog Russo
you can check him out on a high heat at
4:00 Eastern Time I'm in a MLB Network
and then of course his daily radio
extravaganza on Sirius XM at 5:00
Eastern Time live from Nationals Park
speaking of high heat Pedro Martinez in
studio in person next hour along with
Steve Garvey all right
you have the floor and Wimbledon why
should people care about it Chris well I
mean I think that's the best tournament
in the world still I in the world oh
yeah I'd have much better than US Open
the traditionary talking tennis though
tennis okay
tennis adolphus got the Masters but I
tell Wimbledon had a tremendous last
five days and I got two big issues that
are interesting number one they got a
play a tiebreaker when he's fifth sets
he can't have Kevin and you can't have
Anderson and is gonna play 50 games and
set five that takes three hours and 33
minutes and then have Anderson the
winner or is their comeback forty-eight
hours later it's too difficult that's
number one so they're gonna have to do a
tie-break in Wimbledon doesn't move that
quickly they're Glade you know who we're
Wimbledon don't tell us what to do then
one of those mm-hmm but they need to
implement a tiebreaker think about what
this tiebreaker caused not having won on
Friday they played until they played six
hours which meant that Djokovic and
Nadal played after they could not get
the match they stopped because 11
o'clock curfew which is a hard curfew
right so they had a start again on
Saturday and then the women got annoyed
and a WTA and they're wrong but they got
annoyed because remember they played
them at 8:00 a.m. Eastern Time locally
at 1:00 the women's match starts at to
struggle rich Nadal goes two and a half
hours so the women did not know what
time they were gonna start their final
mm-hmm and everybody wrote moaned and
groaned how do you do this to the women
blah blah blah
what did you want Wimbledon to do play
Djokovic and Nadal at 6 o'clock at night
after the whim of the after the women's
final and then have the winner have to
play the next day so they did the right
thing Wimbledon but because of that long
tie breaker right it screwed up their
host schedule remember there's to the
fans aboard the tickets Friday for the
men's Emmys now they got their money's
worth but they didn't see the conclusion
because that's it did not work on
Saturday that's so keep that in mind
keep that in mind as well
that's the other thing I was the first
of all Sheena was awful
I've never seen her play where she's and
that's I gives give Kerber credit buts
mean I'm as bad as I've ever seen her
but think about this Djokovic now is 113
majors mm-hmm okay Nadal 17 in Federer
20 now you can make an argument that
Djokovic is the best player of this era
he has beaten Federer at Wimbledon twice
he beaten a doll at the French Open he
beat Nadal this year's Wimbledon he
beaten a doll at the Australian Open you
can make an argument when all three of
them are Annie and he's got a winning
record against Nadal 27 and 25 he's got
winning winning again winning record
against Federer so you can make an
argument
everybody talks Nadal Federer that
Djokovic is better than both of them
that's how good he is
I mean Djokovic is a tremendous tennis
player now you you say you can seven
majors or seven majors and there is
something for longevity and Federer has
that right now I've just Federer I
remember when I was doing the US Open
with you back in the day was sports yes
same thing with me but just watching
Federer in person he doesn't sweat and
he's so effortless that you never know
when he's gonna uncork the most
remarkable shot he's a the only person
I've seen who comes close to it is Aaron
Rodgers throwing the ball on a road
point good comparison the only guy where
just okay he's just meandering his way
out of the pocket rolls and whoa where
the hell did that throw come from a good
point that's the only comparison I've
ever seen fed looked old there at the
end of that when he lost I'll tear right
now I've been watching tennis for 50
years 45 years that third set on no
puppy food and see it on Friday
afternoon between Nadal Djokovic in
which Djokovic won a tiebreaker say
three set points ten eight Nitai break
yeah that's as good a third set quality
wise as you ever gonna see Chris Mader
anyway no now you I'm going to give you
if I get a chance now yes as always
that work well what do want to know last
year yes
during that controversy yes were you
free hmm as a talk show host that's what
you down deep what you always were that
is what you are okay
were you free to address that dilemma
what the players okay you know the
president and the league were you free
on the air yes to address that anyway
you want what do you what do you mean
address it anyway who was wrong who was
right should they be able to neo should
not be able to kneel was the Goodell
wrong Goodrich eyes and go on now we're
on the air at the same time but you you
want to answer this question well I mean
I mean for the NFL Network on Sunday
mornings oh yeah dressed I addressed
Trump himself you did into the camera
the camera yeah how about the day after
two days after he called players the SOB
so you could think that I've got no
ability to speak my mind
are you allowed to knock the owners on
NFL Network what do you mean not if you
disagree with the policy about I
disagree with the policy you can you
could say it I've just I have not been
on the NFL Network since the new
policies been on the air I think it was
a dreadful decision you did I do not you
I'm not too sure how I feel about it and
players we were at the Thursday Night
Football game last year this net this
group was at the Thursday Night Football
game last year between the 49ers and the
Rams on Thursday night game do you
remember and everybody thinks Thursday
Night Football what is news that was
vacant okay and so and that was before
Jimmy gee he's gonna show it showed up
in in San Francisco that's gonna be a
great rivalry that's a good point so so
anyway one or two players knew no one
was going to do that this year no one
was going now there was concerned there
was concern in the meeting room that if
they didn't address it and one other two
players began to kneel again that they'd
be caught flat-footed late during the
season and they needed to deal with it
now and instead it just made a whole big
hoo-ha and I think players are gonna I
think a lot more per week
we'll be here is the bottle sniffing
watch here is the bottom line Oh for the
players all right this is fact fans who
spend a fortune hmm going to these games
yes waste their use their hosts Sunday
well I've to the poor Park take hours to
get there hours to get out true by PS
else true spend a fortune today do not
want to be protested to on Sunday
afternoons bottom line and that is why
the Patriots are booed the the Patriots
they do not want to go to those games
and listen we all know the players have
the right to do what they want to do
this free country we get that but the
fan yes a blue-collar guy who's been
going to these games for 800 years and
women and women there they don't want to
you know get up at 8 o'clock in the
morning Trek to the stadium pay a
fortune of NPs else and then sit there
and have the players kneel the national
anthem they don't want it it's as simple
as that and that's a you can't blame the
fans the average fan of those games
doesn't want that now you and I
understand you know we look at a little
differently but the person who's going
to that stadium doesn't want to sit you
on this nice happy escape day doesn't
want the world's issues ruining his
Sunday and they don't want to be they
don't want to be protested - well that
is fact and that is that and that is
fact but what I'm saying is that if if
if a player does kneel I mean is that
fan literally scanning the sidelines to
see if there's a protest but now but now
to say that that fan here he or she is
standing up with the hand over their
heart hopefully singing the national
anthem or not you know getting you know
concessions or going to the bathroom or
trying to get to their seat that's
that's what I'm saying is that you know
fans hear about it after the game and
and I would prefer to ask that the the
fan is well whose I fully understand
what you are saying and I agree with
what you are saying but would that fan
then not cheer for the player that if
they score touchdown two minutes in the
mine is he's there to have fun he wants
who first team so he's gonna cheer so so
there's a large connection is a tricky
situation one that I thought would have
been best left alone here's the other
thing I get may I say this this is fair
I'm gonna say that's not going to
sensor you in any way shape before since
that's the undercurrent of this
conversation I don't have any issues
players do what they want is some else I
want to do register to vote a lot of
them more mm-hm vote go vote for your
local elections go good go down to town
hall yeah register the boat don't give
me this well I don't boy he a lot of
guys don't vote only 51% of Americans
Americans vote that's ridiculous
go vote and get the people out of office
so you don't want to be in office you
know Kaepernick was not registered to
vote but you know it so I got cab
earning out there kneeling down all
right now go vote this is a free country
everybody's supposed to vote that's it
that's an to me that's an obligation
people died for people to vote vote and
a lot of the and a lot of players and a
lot of athletes and a lot of fan
everybody they always moan and groan
about how this that the other vote
cat people parkland vote get the
politicians out of office with the gun
control stuff
vote vote Kaepernick did put his money
where his mouth was he said he was gonna
donate a million dollars and he did to
over 30 but he didn't vote
he wasn't registered to vote so a little
bit I'm unfamiliar with his voting
status to be very Lobby he might be
registered now my unfamiliar with his
voting status how can we vote for mmm
but don't you think if you're going to
make that conscientious separate from
from that issue I had a problem with
Marshawn Lynch sitting during the
national anthem I believe in a foreign
country and then not speaking the
reporters as to why he did it
that have an issue with I had an issue
with if you're going to do it and you
were asked why are you doing it and you
are doing it because you're using your
platform to create some attention on
something that you think demands
attention of people who aren't paying
enough attention to it
you should then say why you are doing it
I had a big problem with that I also had
a problem with the chief defensive back
who just got traded wasn't there oh as
the market leaders
Marcus Peters and he on a Monday night
yeah sat on the bench and that day or
the night before we either had a
shooting which killed 20 people
something occurred I forget what it was
forget - isn't it maybe that's the nice
yeah
that you make sure you stand as you
point it is a it is a tricky situation
Jackie tricky too I have one more
segment with you as much time as are you
sure let's do some baseball okay well
when we come back we'll have you vote on
our poll question I even bet okay
well take a break we'll come back with
Chris Russo and finish up the hour here
Ian Rapoport is gonna join us top of our
number three with Lebanon Bell having a
decision in front of him apparently
that's what's going on here from
Washington DC the poll questions brought
to you by the sizzling deals of the
Honda summer spectacular event heat up
your summer with incredible deals on the
Accord pilot in HRV hurry into your
local Honda dealer before the Sun sets
on these great deals ask the poll
question of Chris mad dog Russo Quinn
team has the best chance to win the
World Series
Boston Houston New York Hank I'm gonna
say the Yankees
I bet the Yankees are still the best
team I know the Red Sox right now got a
40 half game lead Red Sox got a little
easier schedule
Yankees having that Sanchez I think they
I guess have better lineup than Boston
and I think the Yankees have a better
bullpen in Boston they obviously both
especially the Yankees could use a
pitcher Astros could use a guy in a
bullpen the Astros beat the Yankees last
year because they had home field because
they lost all three games at Yankee
Stadium the Yankee red sock Euston
baseball is unpredictable who knows one
of those three teams there's gonna be
great postseason baseball with those
three teams I'll just take a I'll flip a
coin because of Chapman because of that
Yankee bullpen I take a run at it I say
the Yankees get to the World Series I
have two minutes left what do you think
Machado winds up into the month I think
he's going to move I think by the end of
the week end of the week I think by
Friday hit be on a new team me number
yes sir you came out of the game on the
third inning right yeah [ __ ] Buck
Showalter was asked after the game and
he's like what do you think what do you
think we took him out yeah hey be out by
Friday maybe I think we'll walk you the
Phillies Phillies can have the front
office that knows them well because they
work with the Orioles Andy MacPhail
brewers need a shortstop brewers need to
win the division
I don't think Dodgers and I will think
Yankees yeah I think Milwaukee affiliate
Thank You stone Tony and the Dodgers
could use a shortstop but you know they
got secret back for next year it's a
rental I don't think the Dodgers are
gonna do that they didn't go crazy last
year I think the Dodgers who I mean
Arizona's possible I'll say Milwaukee
just a second okay
good to see you boys pleasure of course
you got any phone on that I'll take a
Galera the kid from the bra i gr think
what's the thing my my Staten Island
life just came right back oh my god that
felt like I felt like I was driving
around my Honda Accord you got me
through my hood Mike got me through my
day three years ago making me feel old
Richard oh come on now stop you look
fantastic
how many kids do you have for you four
children you look like this 5850 how old
is your youngest kid I'd be 13 Sunday by
the way you just you almost set an
Antonio Cromartie moment right there
[Laughter]
kids 13 okay so I get the four okay
good to see you high heat with Chris Mad
Dog Rousso check it out 4 p.m. Eastern
on MLB Network in the know mad dog on
leash today right correct
5 o'clock ok 5 o'clock Eastern Time back
with Steve Garvey live with Pedro behind
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience